now the winner
ben-hur sampling the best picture at the
32nd Academy Awards now it's time to
answer two burning questions that have
kept this film community in suspense for
weeks
how will the Academy explain its voting
procedure and who gives a damn the the
Academy rules clearly state that the
Academy rules must be explained that
answers the second reason to answer the
first here are some clever souls who
have managed in former years to rise
above the material let me explain how
Academy winners are selected the voting
procedures work like this according to
the regulations of the Federal
Communications Commission oh heavens
February Academy members voted by secret
ballot for five nominees in each
category all eligible Academy members
are asked to vote for nominations for
the best picture of the year the other
nominations were made by members of the
Academy branches specialists in their
fields for example only cinematographers
may nominate cinematographers costume
designers nominate costume designers
directors nominate directors actors
actors vote for actors and feel a film
editors vote for film editors and
writers writers and so on
finally Academy members voted for all
the awards of Merit all of them however
calamy officials do not conduct the
ballot and the votes are mailed by the
voters to Price Waterhouse & Company
Certified Public Accountants foreign
language documentary in short films are
the sole exceptions only active members
who attend special screenings may vote
for them you got all that results are
known only to Price Waterhouse & Company
until the seal envelopes are opened here
tonight as the world and some others
watch
then behold the names will be revealed
opening old envelope is the didn't that
happen try to remember that sometime
is not a bad supporting cast the
custodians of the sealed envelopes are
these reasonably dependable
representatives of Christ Waterhouse and
company and I must say that Price
Waterhouse and company really know how
to keep a secret
they also handled the distribution of
Atlantic City would you welcome Frank
Johnson and Steve Kaplan
that's it for the year hardly worth a
rental now here's the here's a young man
who will present the first Oscar he
wanted for Best Supporting Actor and
ordinary people last year and I don't
know why it is that some of us are
prematurely gray and others are
prematurely talented ladies and
gentlemen Timothy Hutton
am honored to present the five women
whose compelling work has brought them a
nomination for Best Performance by an
actress in a supporting role they are in
the Dillon absence of malice Jane Fonda
on Golden Pond
Joan Hackett only when I live
he was a bit from the govern ragtime
with any Reds
Maureen Stapleton regs
I'm thrilled happy delighted sober I am
very happy to win I was happy to be with
my co nominees the pleasure that company
was lovely and it is an evening for
thanking I'm sorry I'll try to make it
brief
Warren Thank You Diane in the cast the
always great crew of every show you're
on
I want to thank Troy New York and my
children my family my friends and
everybody I ever met in my entire life
in my inspiration Joel McCrea